hablaremos del amplificador operacional
conocido también con la abreviación o
amp y estos son la base de toda la
electrónica analógica el amplificador
operacional es un tipo de amplificador
un amplificador es cualquier elemento al
que le pones una señal electrónica de
entrada y obtienes como resultado una
versión más grande de la señal esto
sería un amplificador con algún tipo de
ganancia y si pongo una señal x aquí
usualmente voltaje o corriente entonces
la señal que sale por acá es a por x
y a eso es a lo que nos referimos con
amplificación y una señal aquí la
represento con una equis es cualquier
cosa en la que estemos interesados puede
ser un voltaje o una corriente y cuando
la hacemos pasar por un amplificador
obtenemos una versión más grande de ella
esta es una actividad muy común el
diseño electrónico
ahora cuando hablamos específicamente de
un amplificador operacional el símbolo
que utilizamos para un amplificador
operacional es un triángulo y tiene dos
entradas una es la entrada positiva y la
otra es la negativa tiene una salida y
también tiene dos fuentes de
alimentación en ella una especie de
voltaje positivo que entra en ella y una
especie de voltaje negativo
este es el símbolo abstracto para un
amplificador operacional cuando decimos
el término amplificador operacional
tenemos ciertas propiedades en la mente
una es que los o ambos tienen una
ganancia
grande
en este caso la ganancia representada
usualmente con el símbolo a es un valor
en el orden de 10 a las 5 a 10 a las 6
muy muy elevado otra cosa en la que
pensamos cuando hablamos de
amplificadores operacionales es que son
utilizados para circuitos de red pero
y mentación
hablaremos de la retroalimentación en
los siguientes vídeos y veremos lo que
significa esa es la aplicación en la que
utilizamos los amplificadores
operacionales
y la tercera característica por la que
se distinguen los amplificadores
operacionales es que tienen este tipo de
entrada este tipo de entrada es conocida
como
atrás
s a
un amplificador operacional normalmente
tiene entradas diferenciales y eso es lo
opuesto a lo que conocemos como entrada
unipolar que sería de un solo cable
y lo que una entrada diferencial
significa es que tenemos podemos
etiquetar los voltajes aquí llamemos a
este voltaje de salida llamaremos a este
de más y llamaremos a esta entrada de
menos una entrada diferencial significa
que el voltaje de salida
es igual a la ganancia por demás
- ve - la señal de salida aquí es
proporcional a la diferencia de voltaje
de estas dos señales de aquí
y quiero hacer una gráfica de esta
ecuación de aquí solo para obtener una
buena idea de cómo se ve los ejes aquí
son el voltaje de entrada y el voltaje
de salida donde el voltaje de entrada
específicamente es igual a
d
más menos de menos
ven más menos ve - es la señal de
entrada de la pampa y le vamos a aplicar
el factor de ganancia para obtener el
voltaje de salida eso se verá de esta
manera algo parecido a esto será una
línea muy empinada y la pendiente de esa
línea la pendiente de esta línea es a la
pendiente será 10 a las 5 o 10 a las 6
algo muy parecido muy muy vertical ahora
una de las propiedades de esto es que el
voltaje de entrada no puede ir arriba o
abajo de los voltajes de alimentación en
esta gráfica de aquí eso se llama
saturación si el voltaje de salida es
tan elevado como el de más decimos que
se satura y se ve de esta manera se
torna horizontal aquí
aquí
donde este voltaje de aquí es menos el
voltaje de alimentación y este voltaje
de acá es el voltaje de alimentación
positivo en este rango de aquí entre
estos dos puntos es bastante lineal pasa
por cero y aquí es donde lo utilizamos
la mayor parte del tiempo ahora quiero
hablar con más detalle de qué significa
este símbolo que hay dentro de él y cómo
está conectado en el circuito realmente
hablamos del comportamiento del voltaje
en un amplificador operacional este es
de más y esteve menos y el voltaje de
salida
hay algo más que tenemos que saber y eso
es la corriente esta corriente de aquí y
esta de acá
un pop amp ideal la corriente es cero no
fluye corriente aquí así que éste o amp
solo está censando los voltajes en estos
puntos pero no fluye corriente al
interior esta es la segunda propiedad
principal de un off amp la primera es el
comportamiento del voltaje el voltaje de
salida
es igual a la ganancia por de más o
menos
- otra manera en la que podemos escribir
esto es el voltaje de salida
es igual a a por el voltaje de entrada
donde el voltaje de entrada
es claramente igual además menos de
menos
estas son las dos propiedades eléctricas
que nos permiten analizar estos
circuitos analizar los circuitos de
hecho va a ser bastante sencillo de
seguro te preguntas qué hay aquí adentro
qué sucede aquí adentro lo que hay aquí
adentro es en un momento entre 20 y 50
años atrás se generó un dispositivo
electrónico por medio de transistores y
resistencias
algunas veces capacitores estos son
diseños muy complejos y por ahora si
solo nos concentramos en las dos
propiedades que tenemos aquí seremos
capaces de utilizar estos circuitos
incluso sin entender exactamente lo que
hay adentro así que digamos que es un
amplificador operacional con una
ganancia muy grande y únicamente con ese
conocimiento podemos saber cómo
funcionan estos circuitos
déjame mostrar más detalles de cómo está
esto conectado realmente tenemos una
terminal positiva
y una negativa hay más terminales en
esto hay una fuente de poder de esta
manera
más ve y tiene que haber una fuente
negativa por lo regular una alimentación
negativa - p y habrá una terminal de
tierra
un nodo de tierra aquí abajo de esta
manera y cuando esto se utiliza en un
circuito en un lado habrá dos fuentes de
alimentación esta será de 12 volts 12
volts es un valor bastante común y habrá
otra y esta también es una fuente de
alimentación de 12 volts y estarán
conectadas juntas y este nodo en medio
de ellas será su tierra
esa es la referencia de voltaje y estos
dos están conectados de esta manera
las dos fuentes de poder estarán
conectadas de esta manera con respecto a
la tierra este nodo está a menos 12
volts y este nodo a partir de la tierra
está a más 12 volts y la tierra está
justo en medio y cuando medimos el
voltaje de salida
lo medimos con respecto a este nodo de
tierra
este es el voltaje donde medimos más o
menos el voltaje de salida
y ahora asumiremos que todo esto está
conectado siempre y solo vamos a
utilizar un símbolo más sencillo solo
con tres terminales de esta manera y
sabrás que todo el resto de las fuentes
de alimentación se conectan de esa
manera y lo que hay que recordar es que
hay un gran voltaje negativo hay un gran
voltaje positivo y el nodo tierra está
justo en medio voltajes positivos en la
parte de arriba voltajes negativos en la
parte de abajo y el voltaje de salida
puede ser tanto positivo como negativo a
partir de la tierra ese es el marco de
referencia del voltaje que debes de
tener en mente
y el off que estábamos analizando tenía
un símbolo así
y sabemos que el voltaje de salida
es igual a una ganancia bastante grande
por demás
- ve - esta es una entrada diferencial
este es de más y aquí está de menos una
forma en la que podemos pensar en esto
es observar como un cambio en el voltaje
de entrada modifica la salida déjame
etiquetar al voltaje de salida aquí
ahora si hay un cambio en la entrada
digamos que de más va en esta dirección
ya que es un signo positivo eso
significa que el voltaje de salida va en
esta dirección
ahora si lo cambio ab - ve - está en la
entrada negativa si él ve - va hacia
arriba entonces el voltaje de salida va
hacia abajo y a esta la llamamos entrada
inversora y esta es conocida como la
entrada no inversora
en la entrada no inversora si va hacia
arriba la salida también y si la entrada
inversora va hacia arriba vas en la
dirección opuesta en la salida digamos
que la entrada positiva la entrada no
inversora va hacia abajo en esta ocasión
y eso qué significa significa que la
salida irá hacia abajo y haremos lo
mismo aquí hagamos lo mismo para la
entrada inversora si la entrada
inversora baja que hace la salida sube
va en la dirección opuesta esa es la
manera en la que hay que pensar en este
símbolo cuando lo ves en un diagrama es
como estas señales cambian a través del
dispositivo positivo significa señales
no invertidas que van en la misma
dirección y negativo señales invertidas
yendo en direcciones opuestas
este es un último truco que quiero
compartir contigo algo en lo que hay que
poner atención verás un símbolo como
este en los diagramas es el mismo obama
pero está escrito en la página con el
negativo el símbolo inversor arriba y el
símbolo no impresora abajo cuando veas
un diagrama que tiene 1 amp una de las
primeras cosas que podrías hacer es
observar en qué orden están estos
símbolos se ve así
así
y toma eso en cuenta mientras continúe
leyendo el circuito e intentando
entender que hace continuamos armando
algo con nuestro amplificador
operacional